now I said as this campaign went on that
if I didn't win I would stand down as
leader of you Kip and I know that you
and the media are used to party leaders
making endless promises that they don't
actually keep but I'm a man of a word I
don't break my word so I should be
writing to the UK you get National
Executive in a few minutes saying that I
am standing down as leader of you kit I
will recommend the Pro Tem they put in
place as acting leader Suzanne Evans who
I think has emerged from this campaign
there's an absolute tower of strength
within you Kip she works in London she's
based in London office and I think
that's the right way for us to go as far
as I'm concerned personally well yes as
a bit of me that's disappointed there's
a bit of me this morning that's happier
than I've felt for many many years there
hasn't been a single F since 1994 that
has not been dominated by you Kip I've
tried to mix that with family I tried
for nine years to mix it with running my
own business and it really has been
seven days a week
totally unrelenting and occasionally let
down by people who perhaps haven't
always said and done the right things
and so I feel a huge weight has been
lifted off my shoulders
I haven't had a fortnight's holiday
since October 1993 I intend to take the
summer off and enjoy myself a little bit
not do very much politics at all and
there will be a leadership election for
the next leader of you Kip in September
and I will consider over the course of
this summer whether to put my name
forward to do that job again